peu
[Musique]
long
il ya cent ans à peu près théophile
gautier se résigner enfin à écrire ce
capitaine fracasse dont nous allons
essayer aujourd'hui de vous présenter
quelques images et dont il parlait
depuis 30 ans oui pendant trente ans il
n'avait pas eu le temps de l'écrire il
avait tant écrit rêver vécu mais bientôt
pressé par le besoin
il se décida à noircir chaque jour
quelques feuillets qu'il allait
fidèlement porte et j'ai le caissier de
son éditeur qui lui remettait 20 francs
en échange de chaque page
pendant trente ans donc il avait vécu
avec ses images dans la tête avec ses
personnages dans l'esprit avec l'idée de
faire revivre des personnages de
l'époque du roi louis xiii
pourquoi le roi louis xiii pourquoi
plutôt il faudrait dire pourquoi tous
ces écrivains de cette époque les grands
écrivains romantiques ont ils étaient
tellement inspiré par l'époque du roi
louis xiii et victor hugo et dumas avec
ses trois mousquetaires et tant d'autres
et bien parce que c'est une époque
vivante par excellence une époque où l'
aventure semble partout avec ses grands
chats poids plume c'est manteau couleur
de murailles ces complots ses duels
beaucoup plus que l'époque du roi louis
xiv ensuite ce roi louis xiv qui a
assagi toute chose qui a donné la mesure
est la règle aux hommes comme aux arbres
bien taillé des bosquets de versailles
donc gauthier rêvait de mettre en scène
de faire revivre des personnages de
l'époque de louis xiii
il rêvait aussi il était fasciné aussi
par l'idée de faire revivre des
comédiens oui les comédiens de toutes
les époques je crois se ressemblent
évidemment aujourd'hui nous voyons
surtout la vedette
la vedette qui remplit les pages des
journaux de ses confidences plus ou
moins fausse de ses photographies nous
avons un peu oublié ces comédiens en
troupe qui sillonnait les routes de
france
traîné par un cheval squelettiques comme
celui dont vous allez entendre parler
tout à l'heure mais pourtant je crois
pouvoir dire que les comédiens
d'aujourd'hui sont très proches de ceux
des siècles passés
ils ont finalement les mêmes angoisses
les mêmes joies la même vie l' angoisse
de jouer une pièce pour la première fois
devant un public la joie de voir ce
public rire et pleurer la joie
simplement de se retrouver chaque jour
pour deux heures de partager cette joie
collective de jouer la même pièce c'est
en cela que cette histoire je crois est
une histoire toujours vivante l'histoire
de l'amitié d'un homme pour des
comédiens qui représente laventure et la
fraternité c'est je crois la morale de
cette histoire
cette morale d'amitié cette morale de
vie et gauthier a l'air de nous dire
comme il dit au baron de sigognac ne
regardons pas la vie par la fenêtre ne
restons pas dans nos pantoufles mais
sortons vivons courront partons allons à
la découverte de cette vie aussi coloré
aussi plein de bruit que ce nom
le capitaine fracasse
[Musique]
ainsi mourut le 11e baron de sigognac en
l'honneur duquel il est dit que ceux qui
viendront après lui lèvres honte au
souper un verre rempli de leurs
meilleurs nectars et prononceront
fièrement la devise qui la composent est
temps que seront cigognes cigognes axa
wali encore non pierre c'est bien ferme
ce livre dont la lecture m'attriste
chaque jour davantage père menace sur la
vie du dernier sigognac qui est connu
quelques splendeur qui peut desservir le
pont pierre vous laisser la moitié de
votre dîner ce n'est pas raisonnable
ne sommes nous pas de à vivre du produit
de mes terres je suis vieux mais quelle
raison et paf mensonge tout ici montrer
l'homme
cette cheminée afin de buchy flammes les
lampes d'huile les murs enfin de lumière
et de vie ces tables afin d'entendre un
bruit mâchoire qui ne vaut pas une porte
ce nom gémissent porte une fenêtre qui
n'en pleure quand il passe sur mon toit
neuf ans lui-même chante qu'il a faim
tu as faim et vous m moi je suis le
maître
je suis rompu le fin et je m'en vais
dormir pour rêver que je demande
il faut une visite d'exception pour que
notre mire au gaspi de ses forces à
aboyer un loup peut-être un pauvre loup
imaginons que nous abritons encore je ne
sais quoi un mouton une poule et louhans
plus de flair mon mais peut-être est-ce
pour nous qu'il y ait là quatre manches
à courir avec nous avons de la visite
nous sommes divers vigueur
excusez ce qui dans la nuit
fract à votre forte sans autre ambassade
que leur voix pleurante il fait si froid
nord que la lune même claque des dents
que les irez-vous l'hospitalité
monseigneur pour mes camarades et moi
même c'est à dire une isabelle une
dizaine
scapin larroy de tragédie un capitaine
de fax et votre serviteur lequel se
partage entre le médecin et nicolas
d'hooghe selon les exigences du
répertoire le chariot de thé ce fils qui
nous sert de refuge déambulatoire s'est
immobilisé devant votre demeure par la
faute d'un coursier superbe cheval de 30
ans et plus de la froidure et la fatigue
ont soudain pétrifiée si je traduis bien
votre langage allusif vous êtes des
comédiens de province qu'un incident
condamne à cette interruption de leur
tournée avez vous entendu compagnon
c'est bien train du monseigneur ses hits
à merveille la réplique
et quelle suite au diable monseigneur de
l'ancien opulence des cigognes à qui il
reste peu messieurs cette cape à
l'emblème des chevaliers mal
ce chapeau que pourrait être le dernier
parement de maras feu portant mettre ici
et cette grande ruine autour de nous
tout se consomme vous ôtera clé des
coffres
néanmoins s'il vous plaît de passer la
nuit dans cette mer misérable vous n'y
serez unis mieux n'ai plus mal que dans
une grange donc accommoder vous de tous
pour le mieux et permettez que je me
retire ou un monseigneur eux pourront
nous sans commettre d'abus
je vous écoute souper souper souper ya
c'est que souper monsieur est un verbe à
ces politiques se mettait parfois mais
l'illusion se poudrer de fantasmagorie
il évoque des odeurs oublié et fumé
disparu de longtemps j'espérais vous
avoir fait comprendre à demi mot quelque
chose que vous épargner la fierté d'un
homme que votre seigneurie éloigne
l'orage de colère que je vois s'est levé
sur l'horizon de son visage
nous avons plus de jugement qu'on ne
nous en prêt d'ordinaire aussi une
sollicité jusque là grâce de partager
avec votre seigneurie et quelques-unes
des provisions que nous autres gens de
comédie avons coutume de traîner dans
nos fourgons la table les sièges le
droit d'allumer un feu c'est tout maroc
est pour le reste du festin nous nous
efforcerons d'y pourvoir à la mesure de
nos modestes moyens vous faudra donc
user d'un enchantement mon dieu mon
seigneur il nous arrive d'en chanter
vous frapperez dans vos mains peut-être
c'est cela peut vous être agréable
voici les ports et leurs outils
voici le fruit le pain et voici les
flacons toute la compagnie par ma bouche
vous prix d'honneur et de votre présence
un modeste repas tout à fait un proche
vous m'avez surpris alors que j'allais
dormir rêve
les reptiles à votre seigneurie
d'assigner à chacun sa place j'aurais
plaisir à vous regarder
je sortais de table
et je crains de ne pouvoir honorer
convenablement la paix qui reviendra en
grignotant peut-être oui cette ligne à
temps il n'est pas impossible en effet
je vous promet en tout cas d'essayer
je n'approuve pas chacun à sa place
il fut un temps où ces gens là auraient
été reçues 7 mai à l'office
il est vrai que nous n'avons plus
d'office enfin monseigne vous êtes son
père fait quelque chose
descendez de votre tard ne laissez pas
corrompre la sagesse du dernier sigognac
par les familiarités ces bouffons dont
il pas eu l'audace de faire rôtir une
couple de faisans en se servant de ctp
comme d'une broche une lame de tôle est
forgée à bayonne
écoutez les écoutez la il rit quand même
chanté premier décès isabelle a dansé
aux bons tandis que le scapin faisait
des tours d'adressent au troisième et
dernier c'est égal les artistes de ces
nouveaux jours ne sont plus ce qu'ils
étaient des nôtres on ne prend plus
assez tous et ensorceleur son ce même
des artistes
j'en doute monseigneur jean d'août ils
mangent
et bien sûr ça me fait toujours un
immense plaisir
j'ai pas de prémix le frère les enfants
viennent sur mes genoux in tire le poil
eux ils m'ont à brasser un peu de
réussite de beauvais a mais rien n'y
fait une semaine parce quelquefois 2es
jeux en pair à dieu mon frère adieu mes
neveux les voyages la route chaque jour
de nouveaux visages à l'oral on dit
plutôt que tu fatigues ta famille à lui
rabattre les oreilles de l'office à la
baisse
c'est bien un peu ça vous avoir jamais
vu qui vous connaissent déjà tous
ils seront un jour que nous avons passé
la nuit ici mon seigneur nous n'osions
bien où vous décidez à venir frapper à
votre porte
bah il arrive que dans ses châteaux nous
jette les chiens dessus le vôtre est
terrible à la nuit peut-être même jour
il n'a que musée rath
toujours est il que si nous n'avions été
tous ensemble et rod ne m'emporte jamais
nous trambly y ont un parent se
chauffent moins il est vrai que j'ai
toujours froid mais peur c'est très rare
mais quoi je me suis tellement privé du
top de jouer des codes toutes les
tentations
je viens de faire les comptes
nous n'avons pas ou trois heures de paix
depuis deux jours mon seigneur et je me
suis permis cette liberté en votre
présence
sauf erreur nous voilà riches pour un
mois aura tes bottes au et toi matamore
t médecine ne peut tout couvrir vieille
bête mais c'est propre agenda
je suis un vieux jeune homme peyronnel
je pourrais être votre père dans laurier
bout sur ce ton rave on doit quand même
raison il avait nommé plus sur ennemis
ce sont les nerfs contre cela mais coût
du film preuve rien pote médecine payer
diverses chaînes nourriture aussi en
prévision
il reste que nous pouvons nous partager
au mieux serait qu'elle fût q-series ces
derniers jours compagnon nous souvenir
et eu un succès nous nous avons à abu
lance un peu mesquine cependant tu es là
tu disais les use
nous partager c est qu je crois blasius
que nous avons mieux à faire que nous
les partager quoi oui mais un mine notre
pauvre vieux cheval n'est pas bien où
ils méritent une vieillesse plus
heureuse que nous tirer sur les routes
sortons le des brancards menaces fusent
et attachant le derrière le chariot et
prenons un remplaçant pour devant les
vieux serviteur méritent qu'on les ait
pas sur l'or
de quel point tu me soulage matamore par
cette proposition je n'osais la formule
est osée semaine puisqu'il s'agit d'une
décision qui nous concerne tous que
chacun se prononce pour moi je suis de
l'avis du capitaine et moi aussi des gaz
nous a bien servis servons là notre tour
lavoine gratis voilà mon opinion mais il
me semble cairote 2
oui bien sûr j'ai tant rêvé que ces
boîtes un grand corps comme le bien vous
n'imaginez pas le mal qui donne à ses
pieds pour le tirer et le mouvoir
lorsqu'ils sont glacées je prends de
l'eau avec celui-ci commun comme un
vieux rafiot hors du sol
j'aime beaucoup mes pieds je patienterai
bien quelques semaines encore au moins
j'aime avec ce cheval fend d'une jolie
couleur couleur de feu et nous
attacherons des sonnailles sur son faux
pour les emprunts courent des plus
paraîtront dans les villages c'est très
important les enfants on nous oublions
le trot monseigneur ces histoires
chauffe mon coeur et ses murs qu'ils
n'ont pas et depuis longtemps le
spectacle de la vie mais voulez vous
dire que vous demeurez ici le plus
souvent je n'en bouge pas c'est une
résolution que vous avez prises définir
le nouveau poste à votre monseigneur
j'avais déjà franchi la loire sans foi
et la scène savent l oms et le rhône
savez-vous qu'on avignon par exemple les
premières fleurs éclate en ce moment
même sur les branches des péchés et que
je connais dans ce pays
mille sources qui n'ont tram est gelé sa
mère il y fait très chaud je préfère la
touraine et moi je cite montauban comme
la vie de la plus raffinée
on m'a rappelé six fois devant le rideau
ya pas deux
[Rires]
elle est plus beau que l'anneau sharp
chartres rien n'est plus beau chat trop
dessus des blés quand nous roulons entre
les mois sont appelés par les flèches de
notre dame grâce et le soir la fièvre de
l'installation
les paysans qui s'approche pour voir
comme nous sommes
on rit autour de nous monseigneur
d'avançon rien toute ma vie et mon rui
sentent du rire de tout ce barrage
monseigneur à manger un grand morceau de
votre nuit
nous vous laissons repose il semble que
ce soit une aventure via merveilleuse
que votre vie à vivre en reclus
j'oubliais les dimensions de noyaux
pendant que je vous écoute et l'entrée
tout entier ici je croyais savoir ce que
c'est que la solitude
mais c'est après votre départ que je le
serai vraiment monseigneur un geste en
vaut un autre
l'hospitalité que vous venez dans les
affaires tu nous vous l'offrons tu
voulais vous dire notre chariot n'est
pas grand mais rend ce sérum les
différents jeux c'est monseigneur tout
ce qui vous sépare de nous par la
naissance mais ici vous perdez votre
rang et votre jeunesse
notre voyage peut vous conduire jusqu'à
paris où le roi a refait bien des
fortunes et la route est belle si le
carrosse branle en mer ainsi que vous
l'avez c'est une vie à ces merveilleuses
que l'anneau comme des évêques
on nous écoute le luron la bouche
ouverte comme des soldats nous courons
de ville en ville dormans l'hiver dans
les rangs joue les auberges et l'été
sous la belle étoile
mais plus que tout mon seigneur une
chaude amitié nous enveloppe
c'est une couverture bien tout ce que
notre amitié de faux prince d'illusoires
princesse vous en font une offre sincère
moi je dis qu'on est plus un enfant
de ses poèmes bien pourrait enlever
comme ils font toujours avec les enfants
qui aussi que ceux qui vous arracherez à
ces ruines que nous sommes deux châteaux
et moi
avec une bonne heure
mais que vos ancêtres n'ont pas ramené
jérusalem tant de gloire pour que vous
montiez dans une charrette que j'ai vu
et qui serait content and moins fier je
dis encore que la fortune tourne mais
que de toute façon je ne la vois plus
beaucoup tourner autour de notre demeure
et que si elle ne vient pas où serait
bon de faire un pas vers elle mais que
ces gens là ne sont pas des relations
que je souhaite au dernier rejeton d'une
racine lustre à laquelle j'ai consacré
ma vie mais que la race illustre
s'éteindra avec le dernier ses rejetons
s'ils s'obstinent à demeurer dans ce
tombeau
ouais mais - n'est-ce pas on ne m'écoute
pas non je dis seulement que la solitude
est un brevet en vrai et que ces gens là
sont de la mauvaise graine
tant que seront cigognes si cognac sera
il ne viendra plus belle isa ben je ne
me soucie pas de lui je regarde le jour
monté sur la campagne
c'est très bon le jour qui recommence
j'aurais cru ce jeune baron plus
ambitieux à son altesse à son âge après
un conflit déjà dix acteurs foudroyant
si j'avais accompli des actes foudroyant
lorsque j'ai un border en tuera le
rapport carte des inventions pour le
public
épargnez nous ci n'est plus permis
d'embellir les choses alors la tranchée
battre écoutes un tiers l'emprise et les
tous
hier ils étaient à l'honneur le rend le
100 m mais avec une des revues mais au
fait n'y avait pas de mes prières dans
son regard et la nuit à passer
pas un mot de lui pas un signe c'est
vrai qu'il ya là-dessous du destin de la
france
si nous n'étions un peut-être trois
lieux où cadre de son domaine j'irai
nullement du raison et ça m'a d'abord
bien récite nous ton couplet sur la
manière de demander un jour
abba l'instant que je compose la
physionomie attend quoi monseigneur on
nous regarde un peu où où nous trois
c'est bien puisque on en use ainsi avec
le digne successeur des reculs et
d'asile puisque on oublie mettra vos
anciens et mes succès passés j'en veux
accomplir de nouveaux qui effaceront
tous les autres et en aboliront jusqu'au
souvenir même regard de monsieur
entarteur ce grand prix gold est réel ou
dragées canonnade paraissait monsieur
avant que de mal rage ne décroche la
lune et l'australie
boulez je t'attends sigognac montre toi
si tu l'as montgaillard ici et mon
chapeau attention s'est fait une belle
frayeur à l'autre le capitaine vous
l'avez reprenant teva louis borloo doit
par action pardonnez moi mes amis j'ai
voulu mettre quelque distance entre moi
et c'est passé une seule chaise par
lequel je m'engage à partager quelques
temps votre avenir
oui je lave ou si nous avions rencontré
ensemble quelques équipages de chasse
aux armes d'une maison au moins noble
que la mienne mais plus habiles à
préserver ses biens et que l'on eut
reconnu j'aurais eu un oui honte pour
vous qui vous embarrasser d'un pauvre
diable de mon espèce pour ménager votre
pudeur et votre rang monseigneur adapté
de cet instant plus de monseigneur ni de
rang ni de titre
le premier de nos masques s'appelle
incognito
nous vous offrons un autre pour l'heure
nous avons un compagnon ch plus allongé
sa vie ils connaissent la chaleur de
notre maternité
de la comédie romaine sus des grands
chemins
des rois des points que des génies des
maths à mort death cap
je vois près par eux des chants de
il se pourrait
qu'avec la nuit
tu reçoives non urbain
noël
peut-être senti passer par une autre
route ont bien vite u19 et il y avait la
dame au collier
une autre dame sans collier et puis
quatre ou cinq grands bavards et tu es
bien sûr que c'était des comédiens et
rien de plus
sur précieux ils ont dîné à l'auberge et
les ont payé le plus grand film matamore
et le plus pâti de ce capteur est le
plus beau ne faisait rien que sourire et
il s'est presque fâché une fois parce
que quelqu'un la plaie monseigneur
monseigneur chap que diable monseigneur
qui voyagent ainsi ne peut être un grand
personnage en quête d' aventure
et tu sais ce que ça veut dire un grand
personnage c'est une bourse piano baise
un gros ventre de bourse remplie d'une
quantité prodigieuse d'études à chippis
tard s'ils ont réussi ce coup là je te
donnerai je te donnerai aux énormes
croûtons frotté d'ail à les appelle
encore petite fille je n'appellerai plus
si tu ne mets promet mme écoliers que
j'ai vu au cou de la jeune dame du bien
soit le collier le croûton à l'aimer
appellerons me semble entendre
ynwa atteint 2 grassement des cieux il
va te tuer tous - vous l'entendez frères
truand conseil de tuer loin possible
eh bien ça je te montrer habile et la
surprise est tombé dans un guet-apens
coupât bras et jambes à tous ces
imbéciles et s'il ne se défendent pas
trop eh ben on leur laissera la vis aux
allées appel de bon gré sinon je
t'oublie jeu rapide parce que oui libre
établi ne ferme jamais l'être mais il
faut toujours mais tient werder amis
s'appellent arrêté un instant je les
vois et entends rien si j'ai cru
entendre des appels et soyez prudents il
arrive que le diable la nuit prennent la
voie d'un enfant pour attirer le
chrétien dans ses pièges
soyez prudents nous avons accueilli
parmi nous un bien fou lucas marc
amateurs
le monde
me semble apercevoir une lanterne
appelle encore y appelle aussi à aa qui
s'approcherait
oui j'avais cette fillette et sera
probablement égaré ou volé une cheville
n'apparaît pas
voici de l'est bonjour monsieur est
celui qu'ils ont appelé mon seigneur
alors de beaumont szpiner ait pas un
geste
ma petite trop bizarre comme usera douce
bras tous plus vaillants les ath les
eaux monseigneur jeter votre clef s'il
vous plaît venez l'ouzo aucun tu te sers
d'une enfant pourtant dans ces pièges le
collier qu'il est beau et maintenant un
coup en l'air pour effrayer vos
valeureux camarades mais monseigneur
cette petite et ma fille est elle me
coûte de l'argent jna nourris et je lui
apprends la vie en échange de quoi elle
me rend quelques menus services
monseigneur votre bourse
et si je n'en avais pas monseigneur je
serais désolé de vous tuer mais croyez
bien joe fresh alpha alors tu moins
visibles en plus désemparés les autres
prenez garde que les autres ne dit
qu'ils ne peuvent pas ce sont des
mannequins peyras pensons ce que tu te
diras épisode mais voilà pas un geste
monseigneur sinon cette jeune poulette
reconnaître à la broche que vous m'avez
confié je suis de chair et d'os moi et
j'ai le bras solides votre remboursement
seigneur sinon gens proches cette chaîne
poule est aussi vrai que j'ai déjà auxi
plus de 12 de vos semblables
nicole jeu c'est de là aussi vrai que
j'ai expédié par le monde plus de 100
pts et confrère jeunes moi je leur dois
aux pitié ayez pitié d'un pauvre
misérable
c'est la misère qui macule dans ses
derniers retranchements monseigneur mais
ses personnages le sombre des mannequins
d'osier mais c'est vrai la petite a
raison ça je suis pas mauvais au fond le
monseigneur je tue pas mauvais
on cite monseigneur je suis pas mauvaise
et des des épouvantails des brigands
c'est pour les moines aux du mérite
d'abord au nom et ron nom est tu vas
mourir de l'ontt indécis la cité
brigands ne sont que des images de
brigands fait avec de l'osier biec
dépouille
cet ep n'est qu'une épée de pau à mon
ami il aurait bien été empêchés de
trancher le cou avait co malédiction
film et quand je me rends plus sur la
route j'ai le bras solides moi aussi je
te donnerai la fessée sur les tréteaux
du trial fils où je t'écris la part
totale tuerie avec nous
cet homme n'est donc pas ton ami il dit
aux gens qui les montagnes et je ne nie
pas alors je crois que ce n'est pas vrai
car on aime toujours ce faire c'est un
joli collier il te plait oui j'avais
demandé à ghosta de me le donner
lorsqu'il vous l'aurez vaut le coup je
te le donne pour que plus jamais tu ne
sais me laisse penser tiens le voilà au
il ne vaut pas beaucoup mais je te
l'offre de grand coeur toi je ne
dévoilerai jamais rien je t'aime toi
comment tu nommes puce chikita et toi
isabelle
quand je me marie v j'appellerai ma
fille isabelle qu'elle soit aussi belle
que toi
les amis ou les amis
mauvaise nouvelle ne tracasse notre
pauvre vieux cheval
nous avons trop tardé pour lui trouver
un remplaçant
les sons se répondent il est mort c'est
le froid qui l'a vaincu l'auberge de bel
ombre est proche
nous reviendrons demain chercher nos
affaires dans le chariot ou suivez moi
ne perdez pas de vue ma lanterne
ces gars et par le temps qu'il fait ne
serait pas bon y'a du camarade
oui je vous suis je connais le chemin
qui reste à parcourir
je vous suis
non
non je ne vous suis pas quelque chose
vient de se briser dans ma poitrine
voilà qui vous autres à l'envi de faire
un seul geste qu'aucun je suis matam a
annonc é je le vois vous glacent
d'effroi et paralyse moment brazza bo
qui a parlé toi toi toi toi aulas a mais
c'est qu'on vous connais vous met à tous
un nom sur la figure diskuizh bailleval
de narbonne mme atassi herpen tout
honnête et meurent de rouge et barbe
bleue
ah ah et toi la vie d'un lot chevaliers
de la belle étoile et prince des mots
vérifiant trop allez sortez de là tous
ensemble
s'il vous plaît enfin un après l'autre
si vous préférez aller prenez moi je
reste ou là comme un chien d'arrêt je
ratais est seul face à la meute plus à
nos plus sincères un drone 20 ans les
fonds souffre et méchant s'il n'y avait
les 1000 poignard du gel il me fout il a
mais le core i7 et l'univers qui mettra
le coeur
il fait froid voilà à vous tremblez sont
aussi drôles je vais rejoindre mes amis
mais je reste un oeil sur chacun de vous
et surtout ensemble mon dieu comme un
peu le soleil serait le bienvenu mon
coeur est une qui
dans ma vaste impôts intense compagnon
attendez-moi chef n'hésite pas
il aura droit givre sur ton et nous
retrouvons mes amis mais sera pas repris
mais j'avais fermé l'aube était comment
se porte à l'illustré compagnie d'angers
fut naguère le bouffon au bourreau
tamara d' eau
nous avons perdu notre vieux cheval à
moins du lieu
la pauvre bête nous attirer tant que la
eu des forces les nôtres sont usés or en
prêt à me rentrer au chaud chez toi
bonjour nous bien aurez-vous délits dits
moins qu'en libye pour tous et des draps
je ferait trop plaisir qu'on a de
s'étendre après des heures de route de
chaos les reins brisés c'est autre chose
que de la prague où je vous présente un
renégat de la rate et froch du théâtre
mais un ami demeurer très fidèle bellon
et que vous soyez monsieur ne l'écouté
pas j'ai renoncé au peinard de scène
c'est vrai mais non pas par dépit
ni de mauvaise manière non ne joue plus
comme on joue et je vieillis il faut
apprendre aujourd'hui le texte des
poètes d'être plus soi-même
le poète qui invente le monde et
mimiques l'épaule situations les
dénouements
on joue jusqu'à dix fois de suite la
même comédie non plutôt que d'être
chassé du théâtre par les sifflets d'un
public que je servirai mal j'ai pris
congé dans la fleur de mon talent mais
le coeur n'a pas changé mais où se
cache-t-il le maire
à merveille l'admirable matamore dans
mes bras
maintenant on fait quoi il était
derrière mon avis hein je crois qu'il
est passé devant tant nous marchions non
non non je n'ai pas vu ni moi mais moi
si maigre qu'il soit je leur ai aperçu
peut-être milieu des arbres et roth
s'est il trompé sans dieu il clôt cet
attentat grotesque m'a troublé l'esprit
j'aurais dû l'attendre mais qu'un
attentat enjeux techniques ray des
lanternes aux vite
le pauvre doit claquer des dents me
retrouvant le chemin creux du ces il a
peu de santé de lanternes vite il faut
la tortue de terre
m
[Musique]
ainsi les yeux ce qu'apple vite
il ya de la joie
comment va le croire
ça peut pas un grand malade
il ne l'est plus
une joue et d'une sortie altérables
désormais plus de fièvre plus d'angoise
il est à tout jamais guéri de cette
maladie pour laquelle aucun médecin n'a
trouvé de remède
je veux dire la vie dont on finit
toujours par mourir c'était un bon canal
adieu l'ami de vous il m'a bien rejouer
mais ainsi couché qu'elle prenne une
sphère alors tenez ce rapace camarades
comme un arbre tombé sur cette campagne
du maine après tout est leur seul
baptême en portant le et puis ce qui
n'est pas permis le compte est dénué
parmi les tendres qui tourne autour de
l'église nous l'ignorons sous un grand
tilleul que j'ai derrière l'auberge il
embrassera de ses racines et lui fera de
l'ombre l'été très doucement doucement
doucement mes amis vous savez bien comme
il était tout y est ce grave
là
ça
je vais
à
animal defenders père miséricordieux
tu as
vous
chaud non plus mais ouais
le meilleur expliqué je me plaindrai pas
pour ses camarades au jus pomper plus
d'eau dans la terre pour que le tilleul
vie mais maintenant que nous avons le
cheval il va commencer avec ses bottes
voilà qui trouvera je n'ai pas vu notre
nouveau pick a dream whiting bien
j'allais bien solide mais totalement
superflue la pièce choisie
je me connais un peu en jeu pour yves
mènera poitiers 1 3 jours auteur et
votre chariot si comme je m'évade et
l'on gratte et laver à grande eau c'est
assez sucré très bien que j'aimerais
vous suivrez lancé mais la roue tourne
une bonne force et les visages qui est
là-dessous là dans un grand rire quand
même les rodomontades de matamore quel
succès hélas sa mort avait ressuscité le
voter entre comme à la cour
le roi est mort vive le en moi que tu
dire mais la seule chose qui soit
raisonnable matamore n'est plus vive
matamore remplacer le oui oui des
mourants placé matamore mais qui le
remplacera moi si vous m'accepter
monseigneur si cognac
la proposition est sérieuse elle est le
remplacer sur les tréteaux dans le coach
vous avez je brûle de l'accepter enfin
monseigneur genoud vous me trouvez bien
téméraire
non non non c'est à vous que je pense
matamore notamment n'est pas un emploi
de héros c'est un dos qui reçoit des
cours le patton
il est tout ce que vous n'êtes pas là
charmant traveller vous êtes sigognac et
baron von être ni l'âge ni menteur ni
l'ampleur c'est vrai mais ne vous ai pas
entendu dire qu'on ne réussit à
merveille en comédie qu'en se donnant
l'emploi contraire à sa véritable nature
vous jouez les pédants blasius et vous
êtes à simplicité même rien de plus
honnête que scapin et rang des bons ils
n'appellent plus et cependant il fait le
sanguinaire il joue les rouges je serai
très large et très ridicule si vous
n'acceptez et me donner un autre nom que
cigagna pour moi je vous trouve super
décider ce qu'il vous plaira je vais
tout préparé dans la cour pour une
répétition fait accepter qu elle
fracasse
il serait capitaine fracasse l'eau
chaude longueur très pro
et maintenant voyez les professeurs de
temps me dit je vous être digne de vous
par ma part des montants très élevés à
la poubelle nous répétons s'enlève des
siens sont rentrés dans ta grande groupe
pourrait alors mettre une chambre op est
le mark et débrouillez vous voyez ici
vous le connaissez vous les connu sortez
d'ici vous autres c'est un arbitrage
dans les malheurs en déranger à moins
que vous ne désiriez le savez si les
deux anciens amis non il n'est pas mais
sa musique attendez vous vous mettiez
lavoine pour mon cheval pour moi du vin
chaud aulas
[Applaudissements]
de même avant même d'ouvrir la bouche
vous avez posé votre personnage lesparre
intéressés et et amusé et surtout la
première occupation doit être de marché
il faut marcher avec plus de solennité
avec application mais aussi fait sentir
le poids de votre épée le le gros effort
n'a jamais vu de dignité encore quoi
lever la tête c'est simple à la poitrine
la poitrine la jambe c'est ça plus de
dignité respirer vos luminaires moyen
tournait journée non non non d'une pièce
voilà je vais montrer
n'est ce pas
et hop à 20 dont tout le grand test
d'une dinde
vous avez une oreille à l'affût des
bruits dont le moindre on vous fera
sursauter
c'est à dire est un film habilité et
elie baup les minorités dans les grands
moments des terreurs vos genoux sera
entre aux chocs votre visage se
déchirent de tic vos yeux roulent
oui mais nous ne sommes pas dans quoi là
allez-y c'est le terme
sachez encore bien très bien attention
quelques insurgés au capitaine est en
train de naître
jim on s'étonnera tu l'auras pas grand
chose a changé à tard en cela par un mot
un nom pas plus le lorientais
je dois avoir trouvé des taux d'enfants
est bien trop loin dans nos travers la
parole ça va à nouveau tout beau je me
sens que le grotesque je m'entends bien
dans le corps c'est vrai mais nous
sommes surtout camarades
la seule chance est de reproduire ces
mêmes gestes devant tout un public dans
tous les yeux seront là à observer à me
dévorer le visage
il omet de l'autruche dont on dit
qu'elle se croit invisible lorsque une
feuille simplement lui dissimule le
paquet les deux rendez-vous est fixé
je ne suis plus le même hollande et vous
aperçu celui qu'on a mais si bagnac
baron chevaliers de malte est
propriétaire des fabuleuses contre et
sur laquelle veille les montres un viol
et non on ne voyait pas vous ne verrez
plus c'est impossible je les tue dans
une auberge de vente une assemblée de
plus fin qu'un dessert aussi vrai que je
suis capitaine les trois grâces de les
tuer aussi près ce soir occasion une
hutte spectacles représentations est
ordinaire ville illustre comédiens qui
ont eu l'honneur de jouer devant des
têtes couronnées et des belles 200
donneront une représentation une île
sont attendus à paris où la tour
oh non une pièce qui s'intitule des
rodomontades du capitaine sans payer
petites ruses et gibert et pour elle je
suis vu notre joie ne me trompe pas j'ai
beaucoup marché pour trouver le
rejoindre il m'a battue je me suis enfui
et me voilà je reste avec toi je suis
dit ah c'est impossible enfin que l'idée
je croyais qu'il m'aimait bien nuit je
t'aime tu as raison mais ce n'est pas
mon père on me l'a dit les autres
enfants ont pas fait moi je n'en ai pas
si tu ne fais pas noir propos collier je
n'entrerai pas près de lui
comment vivre tue comme but les renards
ou les autres bêtes dans les bois garde
le collier jaurès avec toi comme la vie
lui paraissent où il faut l'aider
je crois qu'il le faut en effet gardons
là quelques jours avec nous le temps de
la raisonner le mal ne pas grand regarde
bien que nous pouvons lui faire tu me le
prêt regardez ce que j'ai fait c'est
resté cette année là jusqu'à pointe yeux
là vous la remettrai à l'évêché
aubergines de soucis bien de ses salles
d'attenté pour être sympa sion
bien vu la naissance à lux au djihad
mois et puis tout ce bruit nous est
insupportable de source de tracas
la petite que non et 1h temps monsieur
qu'il ne s'agira si oui où cela il me
semble bien pourtant que c'est une
petite gueule non si vous prenez les
personnes comme moi pour ce que vous
dites c'est que vous êtes un grand sage
le bien jeux et cartes toi on me tutoie
grands dieux
avons-nous accompli ensemble de ses
exploits dont je me flatte d'avoir
rempli le monde je n'en n'ai pas la
mémoire et carte toi sinon sinon je te
connais assez la tête donc dû perdre
toute la mémoire c'est il me ferais je
sais qu'il me ferait trembler on se
découvre
il paraît que monsieur va nous présenter
des excuses qu'elle s'excuse
il s'en prendre qu'à mais jenson quant à
moi mon seigneur ce n'est pas vous qui
avait injurié ce n'est on pas de faux
que j'attends réparation mais tu dis
bien bouffon non c'est un seul ont
refusé de l'entendre quand je les ai
très courtoisement priés de modérer
leurs fièvres déclamatoire exact mon
seigneur il nous a fort courtoisement
traiter de noms et de grotesque il
aurait bien l'humour sait tous on
voulait battre cette fille est con
seigneur comme en suisse interposés
battre ce qui n est pas pressé dit
qu'ils voulaient je suis le marquis les
bruyères tous les villages alentour
m'appartiennent vieux sur mes terres
rouges interdit que stationnent toujours
de ton espèce gitane et aux
saltimbanques et roumanie seule mais
madame jocelyn merad hall c'est bien toi
vieux camara
il ne touchera pas un entre nous
monseigneur cet homme a menti sur mon
honneur je soutiens on ne met pas de
l'honneur et taison et qu on l'obligé
pas à me découvrir monsieur je peux
endurer se massent ce que je n'en dirai
pas le masson masque mirandol fouette ce
qu'aucun signal ou souvient-il d'un
certain duel sous les murs du château de
ma nombreuses et qui voulait ça cette
marque que je vois encore sur votre
visage
j'étais très jeune en valeur et ce
pendant mon vous m'auriez tuer sans
soucis de ceux trop jeune âge
aujourd'hui je suis un homme et je pose
ma parole à celles de ces menteurs
choisissez entre nous mais si vous
choisissez mal craignent l affronter cet
ep qui a beaucoup appris depuis son
premier duel en garde ce que n'a pas su
nous soir c'est du bon
quid rometty ce mouvement je n'ai vécu
mais on n'a pas su le faire
voilà qui n'arrange pas les affaires
kamal omari podiums en tout ces gens
seraient très sincèrement tu es là tu as
et scania je retrouverai jeunes et
seniors oui venez je veux tu un prix ça
sous l'épaule pourrait vous marchez
croquenots ne laisse pas fuir je vais le
retrouver
yam et dewey voilà ce que vous vous ma
présence parmi eux deux amis monseigneur
cette affaire là centre en communiant
mettre en condition pour qu'elle vous
antonio griefs ne comprenez vous pas que
je m'en vais y est mort j'ai renoncé à
ma condition et à ses usages
mais ce flou est dans la main de
s'offrir ont été provoqués j'aurais dû
plier l'échiné
qu'attend à jabot dublin des flacons
vetri par contre lui m et de grandrieu
entre vous et les gens que je marque qui
ne manquera pas de jeter votre voici
votre équipage
qu'allez vous faire quand les paris le
plus rapidement possible pour éviter les
grandes rousses des grandes l'époux et
dans les granges étables et faites vous
veillez à la toux est mort des paysans
fait diane cette manière elle mange bien
repris mais de vous soucier prochaine
vous n'avez perdu trop de temps à jouer
la belle vie
souvenez vous un protecteur d'un pari
est réservé est clos adieu doit plutôt
de montrer ma plus belle chambre pour
monseigneur se sont ils ont fui comme
des mauvais drôle qu'ils sont mon
seigneur tu étais de leurs amis mais
tant qu'il promettait de payer oui mais
à présent je suis contre eux faut-il
courir après le médecin un bon signe non
sigognac apprécié de gnac c'est à lui
qu'il faut courir la route de poitiers
d'espagne monseigneur d'espagne tout au
contraire ils ne resteront pas dans le
royaume à présent je les ai vu de mes
yeux vu prendre la route d'espagne mais
rien su l'est je n'ai pas confiance dans
ces trappes qu'elle soit en espagne ou
ailleurs je les retrouverai où que tu
sois ce cognac où que tu sois aux vestes
mérindol vieux camarades juste pas un
mot nous verrons plus tard
monseigneur
maudit que vous connaissez ses comédiens
j'ai moi même à me plaindre d'eux et je
connais le chemin qu'ils ont pris
à l'auberge mais jusqu'où nous pensent
que le vrac le plus grand jusqu'à paris
ce qu'il va avec c'est là nous filons
[Musique]
et je ne veux pas moi et vous êtes un
saut très là est destiné aux est en
ignorant le temps car entre gays si vous
êtes un si petit jeu buggé pas pondu
dont la gueule comme il faut et qu'elle
est là pour toi secoue le mot france
pointent au contraire il publie
m'encourage invincible as oui il allait
bien
un franc succès nous aurons entendu à
sanary
moi je savais bien qu'il ne pourrait
s'empêcher d'écouter écoute notre fracas
sites x afin que tu te rendes pas
indigne de pardon par une seconde faute
encore que ce soit ma coutume de donner
plutôt un coucou qu'une parole
je veux bien te dis qui je suis j'ai
fait en avise ses tantes mille combat et
je n'ai jamais porté bottes qui n'ait
tué sans confession je suis adroit à la
grâce de dieu et la science que j'ai des
armes
je ne vais jamais appris ce que l'épée à
la main et si je n'avais pour toi de la
condescendance mortes depuis le temps de
ses discours je me serais mis en garde
j'aurais gagné mais je l'aurais rompu
j'aurais coupé sous le bras
j'aurais marque red bull est maintenant
j'aurais porté le coup de deux sous je
me suis allongé de tiers sur les ailes
marquées fêtes à lapointe est dedans et
là j'aurai à maçonner et pour les
inquiéter castex porté par les ai
passées et tu es toi et plus rome voilà
bien la musique de saintes innocent la
plus grande piquée du monde qu'elles
embauchent au minimum à belencontre
agressé je ne saurais me fâcher contre
se marre vous fois de cavaliers cette
gentillesse le charme
il faut qu'il soit et maniaque or a tué
un possédé j'aurais tort puisqu'il ne
pas responsables des fautes que le
diable lui fait feu nouveau quoi que tu
fasses ayant protesté cela sur moi-même
que je me laisserais pas trop moins une
fois dans ma vie il ne sera pas dit
haro comme toi me fera changer de
résolution il ne s'en est cependant
fallu de rien que je ne les percées de
1000 coups dans les vapeurs de la ville
offusque parfois la clarté des prix
bourgi en effet gelé tous massacrés
qu'on m'envoie désormais des gardes pour
m'empêcher de me battre alors je sens ma
colère tu y crois mon père qui se
regonflent et les toits qui me dérange
de faire un domicile et les graveurs d'
où je ne réponds plus le mois qui
prêtent les bouchons suis fait voler mon
plein vous voudrez plus dans tous les
cas sa série renouveau la raison dans
les cieux bien ça marche
je plonge la porte voix qui fout la
trouille aux citoyens et aux rythmes sûr
que vous êtes sur la scène et quand elle
isabelle je t'aime beaucoup isabelle les
hiboux super il s'opère kazuyo vautours
être en coin une variance
je ne suis pas capable de former des
souhaits mais le second délai votre
conduisait et ma main dans celle que
vous avez choisi mais vous verrez votre
fille d'un visage égal vous montez août
et dont elle nous empêche plus de
conclure nos accords aussi tous que nous
saurons les natures de votre écurie mais
non à la ressource et ses côtés des
maisons je ferai tout cela par les
moyens d'un essai sur le pont neuf la
vie du cher partageront oui je me suis
pas trop étroit
avez vous les contrats ça qu'ici trois
de ses séries tard et les invite à son
point faible les gens sont point mort
qui me les a donnés tabou au masters je
vous remercie cependant de l'honneur que
vous puissiez nous faire mais nous
sommes pressés de même que les chats
fortune
tu ne m'a flatté que contenu pratique
dès à présent à lissieu attention elle
ne sera seul qu'une minute ou de
malicieux oui oui
je pars un sérieusement bongo fils à la
vérité des pas mort mais il est entre
les mains des tuyaux je me suis jamais
content de soutien aux rabat le haut tu
me trouveras mon fils tu le sais turque
le cheikh ben je m y mon gars de
m'acquitter je suis dons libres 2 un net
retard wesh mise à la lecture qu'à vous
offrir mes plus sincères à niamey pour
me venger d'un salon sur toute une
espèce j'enverrai défendre au genre
turques d'être vivant dans trois jours
allez dire adieu de ma peur que je vais
bientôt lui envoyer tout ce qui reste de
turcs sur la terre
oui
nous luttons contre les italiens
bernique ma vie regardez qu'est ce que
c'est que ce passe-t-il son collier lui
la porte sur la ruelle est ouvert
c'était pas possible dauphin c'était pas
possible qu'il aurait enlevé pourquoi
est bien bien là ruraux guide mais au
loin le roulement d'enfer d'un carrosse
nous chercherons plus tard mes amis ne
nous affolons pas nous chercherons plus
tard mais il faut que la représentation
continue nous tous connu un triomphe
allait ou non mes enfants mes proches et
non mais tu vois bien que c'est un peu
toi on va souhaiter alors je vais faire
une annonce qui a fait cela agosta et
oui agosta agosta ma petite fille ma
petite poulette mon petit trésor a ghost
al shaer mieux compagnons des anciens ça
fait longtemps plaisir de se retrouver
pour qu'un plaisir juste pas vraiment du
bien fort tout à l'heure or c'est lui
qui est un mordu convenir à la jusqu'au
sang qui fit au bol a mis trop beau la
vie
je porte vraiment bien ma petite flûte à
piéger les pratiques mon petit trésor on
estime la bm un holà à merveille
je confie ma petite fille elle prend
soin d'elle veille
faye merveille il sait c'est une russe
et qui prendra yable porte à la première
occasion
alema traduit au nom non
lalalalalalalalala du boucher l'aco en
bouche et personnages que nous attendons
1 face à palais les plus fins si que
nakata me chercher et les autres aussi
et tu seras pas tout à fait dans les
cordes sur la grille soit un bâillon peu
plus de temps
allez olla n'avait rien entendu
vous êtes sourd et muet devenait un
millier faux
alors
il
[Musique]
il a répondu à mon signe à merveille et
comme que nous attendons ce rarissime tu
ferme la porte sur lui et mauvais pour
le commerce est fermé sa porte au perron
ne témoigne pas nous aurons à parler si
tout va selon nous on veut sigoignet
puis bien souffert dans mon orgueil à
cause de toi mais il paraît que le vent
a changé
simple précaution seigneur sable précoce
se bouge on dirait un piège une trace
c'est une trappe et nous la préparons
pour qu'elle devienne à pied non
racontez nous tenons là paraît que c'est
une enfant et on est en quelque sorte ma
fille mon seigneur je l'aimé bien mon
dieu que j'ai été heureux avec elle
voilà c'est ma fille et je la mets qui
lui soit fait aucun mal à mon seigneur
mais quel talent à faire dans ton plan
et en quoi peut-elle être utile en ce
qui concerne sigognac votre blessure
vous empêcherait de vous battre mais je
connais à paris un homme ou quelle rien
ne résiste dont les paix semble être le
prolongement naturel du bras et dont la
tête dans le cerveau fourmille de mille
boîtes meurtrier ni la brèche et bien
pour ce sens et qu il se mettra à votre
disposition
tu lui donneras santé cnir
monseigneur santé cul voilà le piège la
nasse que sigognac ci présente est en
effet lui et pourquoi viendrai t'aimons
ô mon seigneur n'ayez crainte alors à
qui vient il viendra wallon isabelle ya
que 4 nous triomphions la pole d'actes 5
eh bien ce ne sera pas une trace des
fois j'ai cru reconnaître son rire sa
voix je me précipitais je montais les
étages aux débouchés dans une couette
par percevoir une enfant interdite qui
s'enfuient effrayés par je ne sais quel
air sombre qui me changer la figure une
fois mr une une mère m'a poursuivi
croyant que j'en voulais à son entourage
vous le dis si cette affaire commune
comme il ou non c'est mon affaire je
n'accepterai pas de quitter paris sans
cette fillette qui s'est confié à nous
vous partirez sans moi voilà ce que
j'appelle un homme
eh bien nous serons deux je déballe
russell qui font qu'à france a un fils
mais pour ce qui est des balles et les
mâles pas question on nous met à la
porte c'est moi comme vous voulez vous
donner des nouvelles de la part de
quelqu'un je peux parler devant ses
jambes et j'ai peu de tension le savez
ici je n'ose penser aux traitements
qu'on ferait parler je vous en prie
parlez nous verrons si cela mérite une
récompense à l'est
parce qu'il s'agit revêt mal fréquenté
ça c'est pas un endroit convenable pour
une fille et vous l'avez vu comment
va-t-elle je vous en prie je suis
toujours aussi pour donner deux à ma
portée je ne cesse de pleurer et de
cendre elle n'a que moi pour amy elle
m'a parlé de vous je viens vous avertir
au radis couronné surtout soyez prudents
moi je n'ai rien dit et si c'est un
mensonge
dans quelle puce mentirais j'ai beaucoup
questionné beaucoup de gens on sait que
nous recherchons une fillette et pour
une récompense
il arrive qu'on avant des manceaux bien
raisonné jeune homme mais c'était pas
menti
wadih couronné derrière saint germain
maintenant chiquita
ce n'est plus qu'une affaire d'heures
souvent
qui frappent agosta
quel agosta du détail le tuer sans n'ai
jamais su par qui moi je sais ce que
veut tu abordes tu travailles tu n'es
pas seul au avec moins bons compagnons
je répondis comme de monnaie
voyons voir ces visages et life d'être à
ce souhait
tu sens la bonne nouvelle
combien santé qu j'avais résolu de
dormir toute une semaine pour me reposer
d'une affaire récente mais santé qu je
me réveille
quelles sortes d'ouvragés hommes les
jeunes les seniors auxquelles je suis
attaché
un seul homme alors ces quelques grands
noms
un jeune baron venus des pyrénées et
déchu au point de s'être fait comédie
santé qu pour un comédien qu'il protège
sans épée redoutable lemaitre dont nous
servons ici les intérêts et le bel force
aux armes
mais l'autre là t'es fait rempel leur
âge ils veulent expédié au plus vite
il faut que tu ne provoque en duel et
comme pour une affaire d'honneur bien
comme une europe débarrassée de ce
gêneur aulas on va bien vite les
affaires de ton m intéresse à ce point
mais c'est à dire que le compagnon et
moi avons affaire au même homme alors le
maître pépon nous voilà je comprends
mieux
c'est clair nous vengeance un sentiment
que j'apprécie la petite vengeance
eh bien nous allons tuer ce petit
ferrailleurs
son nom sigoignet sigognac et ce serait
une bonne lame paul l'excellentissime
enragé redoutons tu mets en soi jusqu'à
présent je n'ai gardé que du bétail des
incapables
j'aime qu'on se bat qu'on se défende un
pack sans riposte nom tandis qu'un
adversaire savant fou gueux bien souple
et nerveux auquel gourmandise la vérité
est que j'ai l'âme très artiste vous
connaissez cette botte 1,2 sur rotule
3,4 au foie rôle là on peut guérir que
tu veux une mort rapide alors celle-ci
hop hop hop
c'est ce qui est le coeur ou bien ou
bien celle là à vous à moi à moi 1 et 1
1 et la gorge et déchiré c'est un
guérissable j'en connais sans autre est
dans l'action on aborde ce serait pour
caen par une vieille à notre service
nous avons tendu un sigognac un piège
oui il sera tantôt radis couronné doit
l'y attendre avec nous et nous lie
attendront
je connais leur a dit couronné en quel
temps une mais il ya eu plus d'une heure
qu'on est ici maintenant à peine la
moitié du année puis toute façon ce
gamin connaît son affaire
je ne pensais pas c'est lui fit
monseigneur le trou à rats vient de se
vider de ces ivrognes
la chance est avec nous ruth enseignants
soyez prudent je vous en prie si vous
êtes venait le moindre mal j'en aurais
beaucoup de bruit et bien voilà une
soirée qui ne m'arrange rappaz beaucoup
les nerfs
je surveillais nous
puis ça soupire al il y avait cinq ou
six ans à boire ici surtout sans qu'elle
sorte d'homme des sommes que j'étais
bien s2 blanc sortait lundi
cependant la maison n'a pas l'air fermé
à mon avis plus vite nous ferons mieux
nous ferons j'avais appelé ciel du monde
on viendra à toi contre toi ici barry j
vous attendu je n'ai presque jamais de
revivre mais vous enfin lorsque vous
arriverez gay je ne vous ai pas reconnu
je suis attaché quand je dis j'essaie de
me sauver deux fois dieu l'a fait ces
merveilles elle toujours aussi vive
elle va être votre et dans un coin sous
une table derrière une porte
vous allez me délivrer aimer leurs joues
roses avons tous appuyé bob vient aussi
à ces quelques jours ces berbères mais
je vous reconnais être imprudent l'étape
c'est bien là que les jeunes est aussi
une condition oui oui de l'aclu vous
ramènera avec vous je fais les lignes de
la plage de sorte je danse très
proprement
mais tin non c'est moi qui rouvre il y a
une face
nous sommes prêts ce n'est pas le moment
de sa fille
cela signifie machinos cognac que deux
otages valent mieux qu'un et que la
soirée ne fait que commencer
je viens de vous dire que ma fille ait
pris beaucoup que désirez-vous mais
enfin évacué g3 d'avoir la clé non que
leur forme la porte
bacci kita
non petit à moi je fais ce qu'il te dit
il revient vite et bien toilé car je ne
voudrais pas monseigneur quoi s'agit-il
de ceux ci c'est à dire de se battre et
de montrer un peu si vous valez la
réputation qu'on vous fait un homme
autonome je suis émotif cinq ans vous me
provoquer vous m'empêcher de sortir vous
attaquer une vieille sans défense vous
enfermez deux camarades derrière cette
grille vous avez un air qui me plaît et
me déplaît vous me richer od vous
refusez de trinquer avec moi cinq ans
dont un seul suffirait comme au roi mon
bon plaisir
le mien sera de vous faire manger la
poussière bravo si vous valez la moitié
de ce que l'on dit sur vous assène mots
s'il vous plaît en garde et élise on
commence on serait plus exact et
personne ne touche à mon petit monsieur
dans quel but ceux ci ont tué il ya
d'autres moyens pas de meilleur que
m'ont écrit pour qui travaillez vous
secrets profession mais on vous paie à
je ne suis pas gentilhomme monseigneur
pour m'abattre gratis nous avons pris
nos mesures aux choses sérieuses à
présent à vos petits barons belle à la
jeune amas les principes une en votre
différentes
[Musique]
jugeant qu'elle poignet mais c'est pour
les audacieux vous la connaissiez cela
situe votre savoir savez-vous monsieur
que vous avez une telle méthode
franchise quel efficace ne gaspillez pas
votre souffle il vous sera utile
c'est une gourmandise père que de se
battre avec ce brave garçon par exemple
aurait certes mais quel plaisir pour me
redonner à paris s'est fait logiquement
vous avez donc loué ma part avec une
parle de raccroc sauvage désespéré sans
tact et genre va prêter rappelle que
vous les respects monseigneur découvrez
vos canaille
cela mérite un coup de chapeau je n'ai
le temps que va pas d'écart faire s'il
vous plaît n'aura pas le souffle
serait ce une indiscrétion que je veux
demander que les gens de votre maître
girolamo paraguay ou aux quelques génois
je n'ai pas professeur qui est un vieux
soldat nommé pierre ils vont installer
sur ce monsieur avoue je me permettrai
ce dédicace à mon maître
c'est une de ces pages favorites
la fois de la glisse et froid avec un
peu plus d espace pour novembre j'ai mes
repères forts et maintenant monsieur
méfiez vous leur presse et je crois bien
sûr secrète mais qui plus est le
résultat de mes longues et minutieuses
et tu l'élixir de sa vie et son résumé
jusqu'à présent ce coût a toujours tué
son l'homme si vous le pari je vous le
donne je vous l'apprends c'est mon seul
héritage
je voulais gré sinon j'en porterai cette
botte sublime dans la tombe
car je n'ai encore rencontré personne
capable de l'exécuter hormis vous
admirable jeune homme je vous laisse un
instant pour prier et n'est plus un mot
vous pourriez me tuer la puce je vous ai
fait mon légataire
désormais je ne la pas plus contre beau
jeu vous appartient premier qui dit
seulement un motion en broche
voici la clé et vibrer les cordages
tiens ils volent tuent me trahis
c'est vous qui vous trahissent et je
n'aurais pas dit un mot quand on sait qu
je voulais revivre une faute un bref
attention c'est vrai que contre lui que
je ne m'a pas plu pour le reste si
l'occasion vous tente il est encore
temps de prendre l'affairé en main
c'est bien ce que je vais faire tuer ses
tables premier qui bouge
je me défends des travaux hier c'est
bien que tu deviens très forte avec la
petite conseillère je vous propose un
petit moins deux raisons je dirais
peut-être d'en appeler si on est jeune
et de layle bougez contre quoi se
cognant en soit je vous retrouverai seul
dans tout et comme inopérables mais ce
soir il s'agit ni de voler de moi mais
de sauver cet enfant pour te sauver avec
les médias hier à dole apprend attachés
et cartons fois l'an pour l'intérêt même
de la ville ce jeune homme c'est
préférable
chacun son dû monseigneur ma petite
chipie tas nous a aidés à le trouver
altran en bulgare dont et je reprends la
fête la terre les crimes d'une entente
sont insupportables ça me rend fou
rangez vos mythe monseigneur ma petite
chérie tu as toujours inventer des
histoires
j'avais une fillette moi aussi je sais
ce que c'est qu'une fillette emportée
dans la nuit le berceau c'est cette
marque sous l'épaule une morsure
un soir que je l'a sauvé des loups non
c'est la nourrice qui l'a brûlée je vais
maudite
si je te reconnais à cause d'elle
aujourd'hui je l'a béni il faudra payer
pour cela
la potence la roue tu paieras qu'on me
prenne d'abord eu mauvaise hommes il m'a
tuer que le ramener à la vie
si vous êtes mon père il est monsieur je
vous attrape et s'enfuit dieu soit loué
nous l'avons sauver cet ep c'est la
vôtre
oui vous n'avez pas sauvé madame vous
l'avez perdu mais c'est impossible parce
que ce n'est pas 8 et costa il
entraînait jusqu'ici un piège il a rien
frais je vois ce que je vois
je me suis monsieur
et voilà mon bon pierre commentons pas
pour gagner la gloire dans paris et
commente on en revient plus que qu'avant
l'honneur souillé par la prison et sur
ordre du roi a invité à demeure ici
désormais 100 ans jamais bougé ce que
j'aurais bien du fait il juge et aider
votre en ces occasions peste j'aurais
bien fait éclater votre innocence
tu lui rien au monde plus têtus que toi
brière gisait à mes pieds
c'est mon épée qui visiblement avait
causé la blessure mais j'étais pris dans
un de ces endroits qui font le guet
témoigne contre un homme et vos
compagnons chasser sans précaution on ne
s'intéressait qu'à moi tu dire de
traquenard ont jeté la victime s'était
accusé un malheureux qui pouvait mourir
alors qu'il venait de recouvrer la
raison en même temps qu'une enfant très
chéri pour malheureux bien digne de
votre intérieur ou vais-je l'accabler
pour des fautes commises du temps de sa
folie il a dû longtemps balancé entre la
vie et la mort pour qu'on me libérer
c'est je pense qu'il aura survécu
à vous entendre faire le philosophe on
croirait d'un vieillard et que vous ne
regrettez rien si quelques amis que
j'avais la maison du rôder autour de la
prison me guettait m'attendre
mais quoi il faut vivre à tracer chariot
nous tenions serrés les uns contre les
autres
scapin chantait quelquefois le cheval
prothèse sur un juron des heureux ils
n'oublieront jeu les soupirs et je les
supplie déjà hier on m vous avez rêvé
assoupi dans ce foot
eh bien il arrive qu'on parle mon rêve
en jeu parler ou si on peut dire ou un
mot un soupir mais souvent répété à
quelque chose comme isabelle et sa fille
isabelle c'est un ouvrier vous qui
s'oublie moins vite qu'on souhaite
laisse moi je n'ai besoin que le silence
étonnant nuit au premier essai languide
vous et maintenant il se plaint la lune
de la gratitude de son maître je devrai
bien aboyer mousse cette voie pour
égarer
pour la nuit et fièvre cette voie c'est
impossible
pierre mireault non plus n'as qu'à
paiements chaque orbite ouvre à ces gens
et fasse le ciel que la folie ne met pas
gagné à mon tour d'asus monseigneur
nimble comédiens se présente à vous ce
sont 1 contraint par les rigueurs de
l'hiver et la faiblesse de leurs
coursiers épuisé à vous demander
l'hospitalité est sur mon ami mon
seigneur votre avis scapin héros du
règne un instant s'il vous plaît cette
familiarité ne sont plus de mise
aujourd'hui les temps ont changé nous
avons un protecteur jaloux la très jeune
marquise desbruyères ou salut mon
sommeil et voici une jeune personne
anobli par voie d'adoption qui souvent à
prononcer votre nom et jamais sans une
douce émotions et me voici votre
débiteur à jamais silencieux je suis
ambassadeur près du baron de sigognac le
roi chez qui j'ai soupé récemment m'a
ordonné de vous lire ceci pour s'être
battu en duel malgré nos ordonnance
le baron de sigognac est confirmée dans
la peine qui l'obligent à demeurer en
son château autant que notre bon plaisir
l'exigera toutefois compte tenu des
mairies de passer de sa famille et du
grand choeur dont il est rapporté qu'il
a fait usage en toute occasion il lui
est accordé le titre de gouverneure de
saint province sur notre cassettes et
sera prélevé de quoi restaurer son logis
lui redonner les plats tout convient à
son nouveau type qu il va de soi que le
gouverneur d'une province ne peut être
nommé sans que nous eussions
connaissance de son visage aussi la
peine qui affectait le baron était levé
pour ce qui est du gouverneur lequel
viendra nous saluer en autres demeures
du louvre ce qui est notre bon plan
louis roy de france je dois ajouter ce
conseil si vous me considérait comme un
ami le roi n'aime pas que les gens de
votre valeur demeure sans épouse il vous
recommande un parti mais c'est que le
roi recommandent ils l'exigent
mais si mon coeur était pris si le
service du roi exige des sacrifices
est ce là la condition de sa clémence je
le crains suis donc déjà plus gouverneur
la pauvre enfant qu on vous refuse
attendait quel est le parti que leur
voile
celui ci qui vive si cognac mais
j'aimais beaucoup pas de passe et
comment fait à la cour pour épiloguer 7
ferry nous proposons un gouverneur un
divertissement dans notre conception
restituer le sparnacien convertir
spectacle qui booste en 2011 tandis que
vous souffrez à vos tapis des dribbles
et les 5 ordi leur comme je viens de me
dit qu'il y aurait de par le monde un
certain jacquemin lambourdes qui m'a
traité de paix litres mois d'hôpital te
révéler ce qu'aucun connaître amara
pierre une 1 soit fait deux morts une
tueuse une formidable foudroyé aux deux
héros celle ci qu'elle quitte un jour la
plus grande et ce sous le soleil on
soutenir une épée j'ai nommé cet autre
capitaine fracasse
non mais
[Musique]